gee I didn't think you liked doing
impressions yeah I did because I can't
act but when I pretend to be somebody
that put a big mask on me that makes me
look exactly like him you can do it now
I can ask anyways our the thing is okay
about pub fiction okay
decide to figure out who is the best the
best guy for it okay no I had to look
into my big misc shaping his head Larry
King used to a a bullet point segment
thing we barely had to parody ecause it
was already so ridiculous yeah but it
would be like you know I like yellow but
the best colour is ourn ah he was going
into the hospital he had a heart thing
and a brain thing at the same time those
goddamn [ __ ] right so I said
Ronnie well you know one of the doctors
say how long how long did they say
you'll be in and he said I tell you I
know I'm you're all right okay he always
said that and he said they they said if
it if it goes well I should be out in
five or six days okay if it goes badly
I'll be out in 20 minutes we always
talked about going back and oh if you
could only go back in time and kill
Hitler
huh right yeah but what a horror would
be to go back in time meet Hitler and
get hypnotized by then like um then they
become one of the guys they say it was a
very powerful speaker you know you know
all of a sudden you're killing it they
say is a powerful speaker then on
YouTube he's I started yelling [ __ ]
christ